and I want everybody to get married I
think everybody should and I think
you're better off in doing so that's
good Morning America's TJ home sharing
his thoughts on walking down the aisle
hey there everybody good afternoon
welcome
to gma3 what you need to know on this
Friday you know it's too bad it's Friday
and nearly a decade before his secret
romance with co-host Amy robach it's
been a great week we just want this one
to keep going and going and going just
enjoy it speak for yourself in 2014 TJ
tried out to be a host on ET a few years
into married life with Roc Nation
attorney Marilee phoebec and during his
audition TJ said everyone's better off
by tying the knot marriage gets a bad
rap a lot of times but I'm such a
marriage opponent I want everybody to
get married I think everybody should and
I think you're better off in doing so
fast forward to 2022 he might still hold
this to be true but maybe with some
asterisks keeping the romance alive in
any relationship well maybe it's a
challenge these days just a little bit
sometimes in the week of TJ and Amy's
romance coming to light ET learned he
and merrily had already gone their
separate ways though we don't have a
timeline the two tied the knot in 2010
and share a daughter hey we talked about
this you weren't supposed to say that
TJ's also dad did two kids from a
previous relationship and just hours
after the Daily Mail broke the story of
Amy and TJ's relationship a past
anniversary post from TJ to his ex went
viral we will spare you America all
right back in March 2020 TJ took part in
the 10-year challenge where Facebook
users post two snaps one from a decade
ago and one present day alongside a
caption reflecting on life then and now
TJ used the opportunity to gush over his
wife writing despite my best efforts she
remained married to me the past 10 years
TJ added that he gave her plenty of
reasons excuses and opportunities to
leave him but instead she showed a Grace
impatience that's incomprehensible
that's true it's like you know your
marriage is like a play land you have to
water it every day is this a marriage
segment or a landscaping segment and
another viral moment Amy and TJ perhaps
doing a bit of flirting in this Tick
Tock here's my half marathon tip ask her
for tips stop we're never gonna get
through this I thought we were done the
source tells E.T the pair bonded over
their love of running another tip is to
train with friends uh you set the agenda
you say here's number
and at least you feel the excitement of
doing it with someone you don't feel
alone
[Music]